the MCU is more than a decade into its
run but there are countless Marvel
characters whose origins still haven't
been told in the big screen
so which characters actually deserve to
make the leap from Britain's Guardian to
a worthy space horse here are the Marvel
origin stories we'd love to see on film
most of the x-men's origin stories are
simple they were born with the X gene
developed by their uncanny mutant
abilities in their teens and then
Professor X found them or some version
of that then there are the mutants who
led rich exciting lives well before
joining the x-men like Wolverine or
Deadpool or gambit two of those three
have gotten their own films and the
gambit movie was in the works for years
then it is these purchase of Fox seem to
kill it and thus a shame because his
incredible origin story definitely
deserves some screen time you Remy
LeBeau
do I owe you money Remy LeBeau was
abandoned as a baby because part of his
mutation his clubbing red eyes was
already visible at birth he was then
adopted as a kind of prophesized savior
by the New Orleans Thieves Guild and was
raised to be a master thief then an
arranged marriage within the guilds led
to adore the murder of a member of the
Assassin's Guild and an excommunication
from the Thieves Guild which ultimately
brought Remy to the x-men it's complex
it's dramatic and it's got lots of
opportunities for John wig style action
set in the hearts of New Orleans even if
you're sick of origin story movies this
one might win you over sometimes the
best way to lay out a superhero origin
story is to keep things as vague as
possible that's always been the case for
the unbeatable Squirrel Girl
a beloved heroine whose name gives you a
very good idea of her power sets but
doesn't really explain why she can take
down literally any bad guy in the Marvel
Universe
Doreen Green was born with a prehensile
tail that looks a whole lot like a
squirrel's tail and as she grew up she
discovered she had various other
rodent-like abilities including the
power to understand and speak to
squirrels themselves what really makes
screw girls are a gym particularly
interesting though is a marvel has never
fully pinned down exactly where her
powers came from
they were genetic makeup resulted from
that of a normal human
she isn't technically a mutant in the
same way that members of the x-men are
she's just different
and she's chosen to use those
differences for good also she's managed
to thoroughly defeat Doctor Doom one of
the biggest baths of the entire Marvel
Universe in her first appearance and
she's pretty much been undefeated ever
since there's no way that a teenage girl
with squirrel powers taking down
world-threatening supervillains would it
make for a great on-screen origin story
Galactus the nearly omnipotence devourer
of worlds has already appeared on the
big screen once but Fantastic Four rise
of the Silver Surfer use an incarnation
and more closely resembled a massive
cloud of energy rather than the
omnipotent humanoid we've seen in the
comics as a Fantastic Four prepared to
enter the MCU it's time to give
audiences the real Galactus on the big
screen all while explaining some of his
epic cosmic background Galactus was born
Galen of Tarr an explorer from an
advanced planets that was one of the
last remaining civilizations in the
universe that existed before ours as
says
eight of universe imploded due to a kind
of crunching effect to prepare for
another Big Bang
Galen decided to pilot a ship straight
into the heart of the cosmic egg that
would give birth to the next universe in
shorts he's the only survivor of the big
bang that created the Marvel Universe as
it was first introduced in the 1960s
passing through that chaotic event led
to his rebirth as Galactus a cosmic
force of nature scarier than Thanos who
survived by consuming the life force of
entire worlds we'd love to see a
character like random paradigm-shifting
in live-action the hoaxes hard-hitting
gamma bombshell cousin is about to get
her own series on Disney Plus so there's
a good chance we'll see some version of
she-hulk's origin soon that said we
still want to take a moment to talk
about why a superhero foundation is so
great and how it ties into the existing
MCU already Jennifer Walters was a meek
but very intelligent lawyer who just
happened to be Bruce banners favorite
cousin
thanks to their childhood friendship
when a crime bosses thugs tried to gun
her down while she was protecting a
witness Bruce struggled to save his
cousin's life and realized there was
nothing he can do in the moment but give
her a transfusion of his own blood
Bruce's gamma-irradiated blood coupled
with the emotional stress of the danger
she was in transforms Jennifer into
she-hulk over the next few decades
she-hulk became a standout character in
her own right while also remaining a key
part of the overall Hulk legacy unlike
Bruce - as you might have heard had some
anger issues
amazing Jen has typically been fully in
control of herself as she Hulk and
actually preferred her glamorous green
form fighting crime and practicing
super-powered law the balance of those
two aspects of her character has a lot
of potential on the big and small
screens if you are already familiar with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and you
hear the name Captain Britain you might
be expecting something very similar to
Captain America like a World War two
hero specifically crafted to be a
symbolic champion for a country in
crisis well you'd be wrong
captain Britain's story is actually a
whole lot weirder Brian Braddock was a
grad student studying physics who nearly
died when the facility he was working in
was attacked by a supervillain that's
Brian bled to death
Merlin yes but Merlin approached him and
asked him if he would become Britain's
champion which would save his life
Braddock was given a choice between the
amulet of Rights and the sword of might
and he chose the amulet as a result he
was transformed into Captain Britain a
superhero who guards his home nation and
by extension the world with his mystical
superhuman enhancements the mystical
nature of his origins plus the fact that
there's actually a whole Corps of
Captain Britain that protect the Marvel
multiverse from threats like the fury a
super terminator that only exists to
kill superheroes would make for a
strange and wonderful journey in
live-action ask any thor fan which
character they're still most eager to
see on screen and beta ray bill will
almost always be at the top of the list
created by writer and artist Walt
Simonson in 1983 bill first appeared as
a new adversary for the god of thunder
but became something much more than a
simple enemy when he lifted Thor's
hammer Mjolnir and was found worthy of
the Thunder gods power himself as
readers got to know him
Bill's tragic story became clear he was
a member of an alien race whose home was
destroyed by the fire giant Sirte bill
was chosen as the great champion who
would lead his people to a new home and
he was given cybernetic enhancements in
a painful procedure that led to his
ferocious appearance though Thor at
first saw him as a threat bill quickly
proved himself to be an honorable
well-intentioned warrior who was capable
of fighting as one of Thor's allies he
proved to be such a good guy in fact
that Odin even made him his own hammer
Stormbreaker
Bill's exploits made him a fan a
favorite character and this definitely
time for him to make
the leap to live-action part of Monica
Rambeau story has already been told in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but she
appeared as a young girl in 2019 s
Captain Marvel nicknames lieutenant
trouble by Carol Danvers Monica was the
daughter of Carol's close friend Maria
so she's kind of a nice sort of super
heroine
we know that Rambo was showing up in the
Disney Plus series one division but if
she doesn't get her superhero start
there then there's always a possibility
that this child of the 90s could come
into her own in a Captain Marvel sequel
either way her comic book origin is
pretty awesome in Marvel Comics Monica
Rambeau was bombarded with extra
dimensional energy from a weapon created
by a rogue scientist as a result she's
able to transform herself into a being
of pure energy across the
electromagnetic spectrum this power has
granted her a phenomenal level of
strength even when compared to other
superheroes and she's wielded it well
Monica is led The Avengers are certain
points in a comics career and she's seen
many different aliases including her
time as a second Captain Marvel and her
current code name spectrum seeing her
fight side by side with Carol will be a
wonderful development we just see the
origin story MS Marvel is one of the
most popular new Marvel characters in
the mainstream media of the past decade
she's already appeared in video games
toy lines and animated shows and is now
set to find her way into live-action
fear at Disney Plus series soon it's
probably high time that our origin story
made it onto a screen someplace after
all we're living in a time when
superhero movies have sparked the most
intense fandom in years which makes Miss
Marvel herself one of the easiest heroes
for young fans to relate to Kamala Khan
is a Pakistani American girl who grew up
in New Jersey and developed various
nerdy interests including a love of
various superheroes particularly Carol
Danvers who in the comics was originally
named Miss Marvel One Nights Kamala was
exposed to the Terrigen mists that gave
Zee Inhumans their powers revealing she
herself had in human blood and was
capable of gaining superpowers to
terrigenesis
when she emerged again a Kamala found
that she suddenly had the ability to
morph a body into any shape she could
imagine from stretching out the lens
from bigan size to enlarging to
completely altering
appearance with her newfound powers she
took up the name of Miss Marvel and
began to fight crime it's a great story
born out of superhero fandom and it'll
be great to see some version of it
arrived on the screen someday soon
Amadeus Cho was created to infuse the
Marvel Universe with a new dose of
youthful energy in the vein of
spider-man since its debut in 2004 he's
gone on to become one of the most
consistently entertaining young heroes
on the roster and one whose story has a
whole lot of twists and turns the son of
Korean immigrants Amadeus displayed
signs of a near superhuman intellect
from a very early age when he was a
teenager he entered a quiz contest for
young geniuses and easily won
unfortunately the contest was actually a
trap for an evil mastermind named
Pythagoras to pray to uncover and then
kill people who might prove smarter than
him Amadeus his family was killed in the
resulting attempt on his life and he
ended up on the run more trying to make
his way in the world he made some pretty
powerful friends first traveling with
the Hulk and then with Hercules he since
become much much more than simply a
super genius including taking over for
both of those heroes of the Prince of
power and a totally awesome Hulk the
idea of a kid whose only crime is being
really really smarts getting swept up in
a world of superheroes and villains with
such sudden ferocity it's compelling in
the same way that spider-man's stories
it also gives Marvel Studios an
opportunity to give Bruce Banner a new
person to play mentor to as the MCU
continues to grow and expand the comics
have even figured out one of the hardest
parts which is making super intelligence
a power that works visually plus since
his mom shows up an age of Ultron we
already know that he exists in the MCU
hopefully it's only a matter of time
before Amadeus himself makes an
appearance on the screen check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail to you don't
miss a single one
[Music]